bonjour à tous nous sommes lundi
bienvenue de votre de 13 ans en basse
normandie pour une nouvelle semaine en
direct du parc des expositions de caen
nous sommes ce midi à nouveau en direct
des jeux équestres mondiaux qui se
poursuivent en deuxième semaine à partir
de demain car ce lundi la compétition
fait relâche jusqu'au village des jeux
où nous nous trouvons mais qui restera
fermée toute la journée aux visiteurs
commerce et animations reprendront
demain avant de débuter ce journal
toutes nos excuses pour l'absence de son
qui a fortement perturbé l'ouverture du
journal du 19 20 hier soir en cause
d'une panne technique à l'ouverture de
ce journal et avant de vous parler jeux
équestres mondiaux ce midi on fait le
point avec l'actualité de la journée à
savoir à la veille de la reprise de
scolaires la rentrée des professeurs du
public les fonctionnaires de l'éducation
nationale sont de retour aujourd'hui
dans leur établissement
comme à caen au collège guillaume le
conquérant situés en zone d'éducation
prioritaire où se sont rendus ce matin
au penny misery lots et plh 8h30
collègue guillaume de normandie à caen
le personnel à nîmes hâtif a fait sa
rentrée il ya déjà une semaine et c'est
désormais au tour
cinquante trois enseignants de reprendre
le chemin de l'école une rentrée
préparer soigneusement par madame la
principale c'est une journée est
tellement important parce que c'est une
journée où on donne en quelque sorte la
feuille de route aux enseignants ou en
colère un groupe et où quelque part on
donne le la de l'année scolaire à venir
est aujourd'hui sa quatorzième rentrée
en tant que chef d'établissement
mais chaque année différentes madame la
principale a donc pris le temps
d'étudier tous les nouveaux textes dont
nous informer son équipe et c'est
reparti pour n'est pas parce que là je
vois que l'heure tourne et il faut qu'il
aille vraiment vont m'attendre et celle
que l'histoire qu'il fait pas pour
accueil des petits nouveaux mise en
place d'ateliers pédagogiques rappelle
les priorités du collège
cette pré rentrée c'est l'occasion les
profs de se remettre dans le bain et
plus ou ce qu avait pris un peu d'avancé
car tel est prêt depuis plusieurs jours
je fais référence croiseur de france
alors j'ai pas autant de choses que les
professeurs de mathématiques mais oui
j'ai préparé mes dossiers par classe
voilà chez tous 10 heures lors de la
pause un timbre et créatif et de
convivialité pour les enseignants tout
juste de rentrer de vacances demain les
cloches sonneront à 8h30 pour accueillir
les petits sixièmes et leur prend une
journée d'adaptation rien pour et dans
certains établissements du secteur privé
les élèves sont déjà au travail la
rentrée c'est notamment là déroulé en
fin de semaine dernière au collège
notre-dame d'alençon qui compte 250
collégiens total sur l'académie de caen
ce sont plus de cent quarante et un
mille écoliers 72 mille collégiens et 46
mille lycéens qui retournent dans leurs
établissements demain dans l'actualité
également une date anniversaire les 15
ans de la disparition de la famille
didar le médecin un caennais habitants
autiste sourd seule sa femme et leurs
deux enfants n'ont plus donné signe de
vie depuis le 1er septembre 1999
depuis les hypothèses les plus folles
ont couru mais l' enquête n'a jamais
abouti sambodrome depuis quinze ans jour
pour jour le mystère reste entier sur ce
que l'on appelle le faire godard un
dossier officiellement clos depuis deux
ans pour la justice qui a prononcé un
non-lieu après 13 ans kate avec des
moyens considérables
plus de quatre vingts commission
rogatoire 18 l'étranger ont été
effectués des dizaines d'enquêteurs et
de magistrats ont été mobilisés pour un
résultat minimes le 1er septembre 1999
le médecin caennais yves godard embarque
avec ses deux enfants camille marcx à
bord d'un voilier à saint malo pour une
croisière au large des côtes bretonnes
quelques jours plus tard l' annexe de
son bateau et retrouver les recherches
sont officiellement lancés les aucune
trace de la famille ou du voilier en mer
à terre
les enquêteurs trouvent du sens dans la
lettre du médecin garry sur le port ce
qui les conduit à son domicile à
tilly-sur-seulles dans le calvados où là
encore du sang a coulé c'est celui de
marie france sa seconde épouse
un mandat d'arrêt est alors lancée à
l'encontre du docteur godard toujours
introuvable la mère crash pourtant
quelques indices un sac avec ses
papilles et jusqu'à la découverte d'un
crâne
il s'agit de celui du camille un camp
volens les enquêteurs sur l'île de man
sur l'île de lewis en écosse on l'aurait
vu aux quatre coins du monde et
finalement nulle part en 2001 des cartes
professionnelles et bancaire du docteur
godard sont retrouvés intacts sur une
plage
en 2006 un tibia et au fémur sont
repêchés en mer laden parle il s'agit
bien d'yves godard jamais les corps de
marie français marius godard ont été
retrouvés alors est-ce un drame familial
un assassinat il paraît improbable
d'obtenir un jour la vérité sur cette
affaire qui a défrayé la chronique et
alimenté tant de fantasmes en direct
depuis le village des jeux équestres
mondiaux on revient à présent sur
l'événement un cheval dans la région
avec l'organisation aujourd'hui à quand
des premières assises de la filière
équine le secteur représente douze mille
huit cents emplois en basse-normandie et
gros plan ce midi sur l'une de ses
entreprises l'entreprise le j'irai qui
fabrique des structures équestres le
reportage de catherine berra et de jean
michel guillot dans la manche les le
giresse et comme les levallois où les
pignolet une de ces grandes familles qui
écrit l'histoire du cheval depuis quatre
générations
après la guerre le père maréchal ferrant
s'est lancé dans l'équipement de
stabulation pour vaches
petit à petit la demande des éleveurs a
glissé vers les chevaux
on est là parce que on est dans un
milieu où il ya plein de chevaux
il ya une demande donc des bars j'avais
dit rêver non alan le j'irai équipe les
éleveurs les centres équestres les
hippodromes les cliniques vétérinaires
il fait de l'artisanat haut-de-gamme du
sur et du sur mesure
il faut croire qu'ils de risques de
blessures au niveau des shows donc on a
une expérience de plus de vingt ans pour
savoir les dimensions les diplomates à
utiliser avant le cheval qui pourrait
booster sa tête et qui se trouvait dans
un couloir des tremblements là aussi
beaucoup mangent boivent bois des petits
détails techniques qui sont nécessaires
pour sécuriser au maximum
c'est toujours les choses mais tu vas
faire là pas de problème à faire les
établissements le jir elles n'ont rien
inventé ce qu'il fabrique est
directement inspirée des élèves d'autres
fois ce sont les matériaux et les
techniques qui ont évolué passe
désormais par la gpao la gestion de
production assistée par ordinateur
le point de départ c'est bah c'est
toujours un croquis à la main ce qui est
pris par un homme seul qui prend les
coptes sur le chantier c'est tout ça
mais ce qui compte c'est d'avoir les
sens d'ouverture des portes
et puis les encombrements part de ce
petit voilà c'est pour faire ça
le cheval représente 15% du chiffre
d'affaires de l'entreprise dans sa
spécialité l'acier galvanisé
elle est obligée de se développer et de
se diversifier sa dernière création un
goût et monnier pour ramasser les algues
vertes
ces algues qui justement avait tué un
cheval en bretagne en 2009 pour
réfléchir à l'avenir de la filière les
premières assises de la filière équine
réunissent donc aujourd'hui à campan à
400 personnes et en direct de ces
assises on retrouve tout de suite
philippe jeanneret bonjour vous êtes
l'administrateur de france galop vous
participez donc à ces assises de la
filière équine première fois que des
assises réunissent pour me nyssen ainsi
en basse normandie
que peut-on attendre d'une telle réunion
d'abord il faut se situe au niveau
régional vous avez dit je crois tout à
l'heure treize mille emplois dans la
région
il y a huit ans ou dix ans il y avait vu
mille emplois donc dans une filière dont
on voit ici en basse normandie dans les
trois départements
cent mille chevaux quand même c'est une
puissance importante et au fond
s'aperçoit que parce que depuis hier
c'est coopérer c'est à dire entre les
acteurs du galop du trot et la filière
sportive bien sûr on arrive
naturellement à coopérer beaucoup mieux
et cet événement renfort cette
coopération sur des problématiques les
vraies priorités communes dont car notre
avis un élément très important pour que
pour peser sur les grandes décisions
auprès nos politiques ou bien qu'ils
comprennent que c'est une filière qui a
du poids qu'elle doit être entendue en
tant que tel je crois que ces filières
le démon facettes ces assises le
démontre parfaitement bien vous parlez
de la coopération entre le monde des
courses et le monde de l'hippisme il y a
des synergies possibles entre ces deux
mondes qui par sa façon un peu clos l'un
à l'autre bien sûr d'abord la première
énergie à des financières puisque à
priori ne contribuons à travers le fonds
éperon au financement de la filière des
sports équestres on pense aujourd'hui
sur tous les grands projets
naturellement qu'ils s'engagent et
un financement déjà mais c'est pas
suffisant ce sont des projets qui vont
s'engager demain pour relancer les rênes
de la radio part il est clair qu'il faut
travailler ensemble dans des villes
école de formation qui va voir le jour
bientôt
donc tout cela se fait parce que nous
arrivons à travailler ensemble
donc le fait d'avoir des projets communs
et les jeux et classements mondiaux
c'est un projet commun par définition ça
permet je dirais de renforcer notre
crédibilité et de mettre ensemble des
moyens financiers nécessaires à ce
développement avec ses jeux et aux
mondiaux on parle de 15 ans héritage qu
est-ce que les jeux peuvent apporter à
la filière finalement je vous disais
d'abord c'est la croissance moi je crois
que on voit bien joué dans le monde des
chevaux le ce pour y pique les courses
se développe
ça crée de l'emploi leveaux lisait on
sait que vous avez une production de
chevaux qui augmente ça crée de l'emploi
naturellement c'est un emploi qui n'est
pas délocalisable qui restent locales
qui permet à nos campagnes de se
développer de vivre le village avoir
d'activité économique donc le premier
objectif c'est de continuer cette
croissance si tous les acteurs
on vous aura entendu merci à vous
philippe jeanneret je suis désolé le
temps qui nous était imparti versé est
terminée les assises de la filière
équine se poursuivre toute la journée à
comme un autre secteur d'activité
passerait tout particulièrement ces jeux
équestres mondiaux à celui des
commerçants caennais hier ils ouvraient
leurs portes exceptionnellement
l'occasion de savoir si la fréquentation
des jeux un impact sur ces commerçants
reportage pierre marie puech et patrick
mertz
et la rentrée mais l'air semble léger un
peu comme s'il faisait beau
je me sourire les affaires sont plutôt
de mode
oui beaucoup d'étrangers qui viennent et
à la famille même les gens qui
participent
on se balade et du monde dans la ville
tiens par exemple les clients et
autrichiens mon frère voulait faire du
shopping pour acheter des fringues on
l'état quand on en profite pour faire un
tour en ville donc vous ai dit chez vous
et pour le shopping
voilà la compétition et ses milliers de
spectateurs qui ont deux pas du centre
ville de caen c'est vrai les rues ne
sont pas bondée mais les quelques
échappées des jeux semblent bien avoir
embelli la fin de l'été et des ventes se
serait pas fait certainement personne
bon et vous arrivez à chiffrer à peu
près quelle est la proportion de cette
clientèle d'une boutique à l'autre
les retombées sont évidemment très
variable mais les commerçants que nous
avons rencontrés ne se plaignent pas
c'est quand même un signe
notre point d'unanimité il y eut d'abord
venu par amour du cheval sont jugés très
agréable constante c'est une classe avec
un petit peu de tout oui on a
l'impression travail et journée de repos
ce lundi sur ces jeux équestres mondiaux
village permet aucune compétents et
programmes et florent turpin bonjour je
vend on revient malgré tout avec vous
sur les compétitions du week end avec la
suite et la fin du concours complet et
ça s'est passé hier au stade d'ornano
regarder devant 20000 spectateurs et
sous le soleil s'il vous plaît un stade
transformé en piste de ses sauts et une
super ambiance dernière journée décisive
donc pour ces cavaliers du concours
complet 12 obstacles à franchir en un
minimum de temps et c'est cette jeune
cavalière allemande sandra au fart à la
27 ans qui va réaliser
on peut prendre la tête du coco énorme
pression donc sur cet homme là la grande
star de la discipline l'anglais william
fox pitt dernier concurrent à s'élancer
s'il réalise lui aussi un passage
parfait il remporte la médaille d'or
oui mais voilà william fox pitt va
commettre cette petite erreur qui lui
coûte le titre
c'est donc l'allemande sandra offer qui
remporte la médaille d'or dans ce
concours complet l'équipe d'allemagne
décroche la médaille d'or par équipes
les français sont 4e et c'est aussi une
victoire normande
oui puisque sandra au fart mon un cheval
normand son nom au big n nous vaut un
cheval né et élevé dans le calvados au
haras de luvo situé au molay-littry dans
le bessin c'est donc aussi la victoire
de la famille blériot qui a élevé ce
cheval pour la petite histoire c'est
cette famille qui a sauvé la mère
d'ogden nouveau jugement destinés à la
boucherie qu'il avait acheté pour une
bouteille dépeint comme byron ça tient
pas à grand chose et le concours complet
c'est également à retrouver sur notre
site internet bastille rennes en ont 10
points france 3 points et faire vous
pouvez me retrouver toute cette semaine
encore toutes les compétitions en direct
en streaming ou les revoir en vidéo à la
demande
ce week end également florent à saint lô
la fin du tournoi de horse ball le
walking un sport de démonstration dans
ces jeux d'équipé c'est bien dommage
mais c'est dommage
regardez le horse ball c'est l'un des
seuls sports collectifs de l'équitation
ça va très vite c'est hyper
spectaculaire et surtout ça c'est
également passé dans une ambiance super
une ambiance de salle de basket et c'est
bien dommage aussi parce que les équipes
de france féminines et masculines ont
remporté pour l'honneur ce tournoi de
témoins création le horse ball qui
espère intégrer le programme officiel de
ces jeux équestres mondiaux en 2018 au
canada cette semaine à l'agenda place à
la discipline reine de l'équitation le
concours de saut d'obstacles et le saut
la discipline la plus attendue un peu ce
que jeux équestres mondiaux ça commence
dès demain à 9 heures au stade michel
d'ornano qui va faire le plein toute la
semaine événement très attendu avec
l'entrée en lice des cavaliers normand
pénélope leprévost patrice delaveau
était bien ce taux qui rêvent eux aussi
de remporter une médaille
cj web merci florent et ce midi on
s'arrête justement sur ce concours de
saut d'obstacles présentation de la
discipline avec catherine berra et jean
louis guillaud
quand on fait du cso on passe des
obstacles verticaux d auxerre composé de
deux verticaux et différentes
combinaisons qui associe plusieurs
obstacles tout le corps de cavaliers
travail des épaules aux talents il doit
être souple adopté la cadence du chemin
est donc un équilibre
pour ce faire ils utilisent ces aides le
regard et les mains pour la direction
les jambes pour la vitesse et la
propulsion le bassin pour équilibrer un
sport par excellence de beauté de
fluidité de cheval le cavalier je
l'utilisé comme un phénomène coupe aussi
où tous les deux fusionnent et on va en
france et le paradoxe de l'équitation
c'est de devoir maîtriser une grande
technicité tout en laissant la place au
feeling pour que le couple soit en
osmose ici poète de rully 11 ans n'est
pas concentré à 100% il est trop frais
c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas sauté depuis
un moment
dans ces cas là mieux vaut ne pas
insister je peux faire une contact je
perds un peu de 2,2 fluidité de
souplesse de son corps donc bon c'est
comme ça aujourd'hui et on répétera
demain ce que je peux savoir sa tête
qu'il le qui disent ok je comprends ce
que tu veux et je suis avec toi et je
fais obtenir du chbe qu'ils coopèrent et
fournissent les efforts qu'on lui
demande représente des années
d'entraînement afin qu'il atteigne sa
maturité sportive
règle générale les soirées la maturité
j'ai envie de dire vers 8 ans 8-9 ans
suivant ce qu'ils ont fait avant mais le
vrai ça reste mon âge et après ça dépend
de beaucoup de choses pour moi était
géré le cheval la qualité du travail la
qualité des soins à la qualité des sols
etc
je dirais que le label vie des chevaux
de concours et de neuf ans jusqu'à
jusqu'à 13 15 ans au début les cavaliers
écume les concours régionaux puis
nationaux
ensuite arrivent les compétitions
internationales de une à cinq étoiles
fusillade
toile le niveau est relevé on aborde
alors des obstacles de 1 m 60 ont mesuré
combien enfants à m 82 donc là on va km
60 c'est pas rien ça représente déjà une
belle hauteur il faut déjà faut déjà un
très bon cheval pour sauter ce teen
d'obstacles là ça demande énormément en
équilibre devant la barre pour que le
cheval le puits se mettre son sens des
limites et à l'arrière pour pour sauter
une façon verticale
quand on pense que patrice delaveau a
fait à quand il a pris un virage
complètement fou qui lui a donné la
victoire
c'est quoi ça s'est passé c'est aussi
déjà beaucoup de travail parce qu'en
fait pas on fait pas on fait pas des
villages aussi s'y relayent sur ces
hauteurs là comme ça y'a pas dans un
garage double g prendre les risques
quelle connexion quoi reynald angot
bonjour vous êtes cavaliers de saut
d'obstacles dans le calvados vous ne
participez pas assez josé castro mise en
2002 vous avez participé aux français
lors des jeux équestres de jerez une
médaille d'or dans une épreuve de cso
jeux équestres mondiaux qu'est ce que ça
représente le sacre absolue oui c'est un
aboutissement pour pour un cavalier
parce que c'est tellement londres pour
amener un cheval
voilà et puis gagner une médaille comme
ça à la fin c'était vraiment ce qu'il ya
de mieux pour un cavalier c'est bien nos
cavaliers bas-normands staut le prévôt
de la vo vous les avez rencontré il ya
quelques jours donc état d'esprit ils
sont avant de commencer ce concours je
pense qu'ils sont assez serein
aujourd'hui ce sont les cavaliers qui
s'entraîne vraiment sur le lot niveau
tous les week-ends donc ils ont
l'habitude des événements la qualité
castres ils l'ont donc maintenant en
espérant que les choses en forme et non
non ça devrait bien se passer
c'est une médaille vous êtes confiant
voilà on est de toute façon on est en
effet nous donc on va les soutenir et
puis on respecte ça marche le saut
d'obstacles ça reste une discipline où
l'incertitude règne jusqu'au dernier
moment la compétition oui parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de facteurs qui entrent en
compte
il ya la forme physique des chevaux
c'est le premier élément
et puis ya souvent des petits aller
à des choses il faut pas déplorer une
boiterie où le mental aussi rendent
beaucoup en compte aujourd'hui vous êtes
ou cavaliers dans une préparation
mentale avant une épreuve
oui maintenant on essaye quand même un
petit peu se rapprocher par rapport au
sport qu'ils sont c'est-à-dire de
travailler un peu cet aspect là parce
que la nervosité se transmet très
rapidement avec avec le schale donc il
faut travailler ça on suivra ce concours
de saut d'obstacles toute cette semaine
merci à vous reynald angot d'être venu
nous en parler ce midi florent un haut
de l'agenda quelques mots de l'agenda de
cette semaine avec au programme dès
demain de la voltige
oui regardez la voltige ça commence à
9h30 demain au zénith de caen ça se
déroule à guichets fermés
mais l'anc de gymnastique et
d'équitation et c'est un français
nicolas andréani grand favori en
individuel qui a donc une chance de
médaille d'or jeudi en revanche rendez
vous à l'hippodrome de caen pour le
début des épreuves d'attelage une
compétition qui se déroule avec quatre
chevaux trois épreuves au programme le
dressage le marathon et la maniabilité
juste une petite précision c'est bien la
famille berlioz un qui est élevé le
vainqueur est le cheval vainqueur hier
du concours de du concours complet s'il
avoue florent merci un avant goût
d'avoir participé à ce 12-13 celle de
cette édition
retour au direct de ces jeux équestres
ce soir dans le 19 20 avec un journal
présenté par emilie flahaut très bonne
journée à tous et à demain